and the
those bills are
very similar
and i'd like to have caitlin right now
would you please introduce the bill so
we can get on with it and then i'll
explain where we're going
uh ralph baum hill vote does it 20 town
litchfield i'm here to introduce house
bill 1626 relative to the unique pupil
identification system and we have
somebody here from the d.o.e to further
tell us about it thank you very much
uh caitlin davis caitlin has to be out
of here by 9 30.
so uh we can utilize time to ask all the
questions we want relative to the first
two bills
yeah
hello good all right great thank you um
for the first bill for 1626 um i'm
actually going to talk generally about
both bills and kind of how they align to
each other so for the first bill for
1626 when we begin implementing the
education freedom account program this
summer slash this fall
we determined that the best way of doing
that work would be using the assassin
numbers to track those students so state
adopt
the state assigned student identifier
so we currently have a system that we
multiple systems that rely across the
entire department of education on use of
sas numbers we have robust systems of
controls built around this asset numbers
to ensure the accuracy of reporting and
data and
that includes
most importantly the payment of adequacy
so
when we begin to build out the efa
program this fall
this asset number was is definitely the
best way of doing that
we reached out to representative
cordelli as he's kind of the champion of
education freedoms accounts to ask him
to
sponsor this bill on behalf of the
department to expand identifier to
include efa kids and we were i was very
pleased um this fall when we started
reviewing the legislation to see a very
similar bill on behalf of the democratic
majority or with generic natori
represent reps on it um that so the
bill's sort of aligned or both i think
wanting to do the same thing
now the purpose of the bill is for every
single student that's receiving adequacy
in the state of new hampshire
including those receiving charter school
adequacy or an efa payment to have a
unique student identifier number so the
department of education can do its
absolute best to ensure that there's no
double payments
right now our system works so that we
have
we use a unique student identifier and
track the kids around the system
we do it at a rate of right down to the
half day of attendance so if a child
were to attend a concord school district
in the morning and then get an efa in
the afternoon or hopkinton in the
afternoon our
our measurement is that accurate
throughout the year we use assassin
number to calculate the average daily
membership which that the payment is
reliant on that
so
we
wrote the language to include the
assassin numbers for the efa children
at the exact same time when we were
writing that language i did happen to
notice that the current law does not
include charter schools although that
has been the current practice at the
department of education to give
assassin number to a charter school kid
for the last 15 years um so i thought
this was a good opportunity for us to
add that
so that's why you will see this in the
1626 version of the bill and can very
easily be added into the 1649 part of
the bill i'm sure it just wasn't
something that was thought of by the
drafting attorneys because
they didn't necessarily realize that
that was also a need
as far as any anything else in the bill
that could be slightly different
um so there are or talks about the
director of the scholarship organization
for efas i think we can just rely on the
scholarship organization in general
because throughout the bill it talks
about
it talks about school districts and
early childhood programs
and then throughout we added where it
talks about superintendents or designees
we also added scholarship organizations
or designee throughout that
the other area that i noticed that there
is a little bit of a difference is we're
talking about the information that's
maintained in the data warehouse at the
department of education so in 1649
line 15 it gives access to the data
warehouse to the legislative budget
office and the attorney general's office
i believe that that ability is already
through their overall existence and the
work of the department of education they
already have that access so i'm not sure
that the bill specifically needs to
include that information
um because they already have info access
to confidential information throughout
the state just through their existence
um so that is
really the bill why we've asked for the
bill
and i'll take any questions on sas
numbers or how this might affect either
or any of the programs
thank you very much caitlyn are there
questions yes represent cornell
thank you thank you caitlyn um we're on
the first bill 1626 on the um i guess
it's the first page on line 26
scholarship organization director or
designee now we know when it's a
superintendent or a chartered public
school the designee is usually the
assistant principal human resources
how do we know who the scholarship
organization director's designee will be
um so they will still have an account in
the in our
we call it the nhdoe single sign-on
system and it's a specific account so we
don't have it doesn't say children's
scholarship foundation account it says
kate baker or matt southerton at the
scholarship organization um or it says
you know superintendent murphy at the
concord school district um so it is a
personally identifiable account so we
could see who is entering that data and
putting that information in
but if they use a designee how do we
know who that person is the designee
should have so even though they're using
a designee the designee would have their
own account in the system
thank you thank you very much and thank
you very much ms davis for joining us
this morning so
um taking a hypothetical let's say
you've got um um
a little stevie woodside that um that is
attending a public school in in his town
and then later becomes homeschooled
and then later than that
um
let's say
uh
you know opens an efa
account
what what sort of information would
and
what sort i guess what what sort of
information would the doe have
associated with uh with that student of
course so um this is just a hypothetical
yeah yeah so for assassin numbers right
now we maintain first name last name
date of birth
and town of residence
and if the child is in a public school
or a public program that requires data
being entered on a student identifiable
level any data that's associated with
that the doe systems do not store sassed
numbers with name anywhere so if you
look in the doe system all you see is
sas number one two three four five
you'll never see that stevie whatever
her last name
his results are x y and z so you
wouldn't be able to kind of include that
information
so various information is tied to that
sas number including assessment results
subgroup information and it's how we
generate
to do for state and federal law um it
would be
things like determining the average
daily membership for paying adequacy it
would be we would also know that cv is
free to reduce lunch so we would know
that he's we're going to pay that school
district for free and reduced lunch
now the department of education the way
it works right now is for public schools
we have a count twice a year we have a
count on october 1st and at the end of
the school year
and so at the boi the october 1st count
a school district enters that there's a
child the assassin number and if the
child was in the school district last
year it's just a continuation or if the
kid is new there's things that we call
entry and withdrawal codes and it would
say you know where the kid came from so
the kid came from
massachusetts public school we have no
information but if the kid came from
another school district information
would follow them
and we would be able to link them back
over there now schools are required for
the purpose of reporting things like
graduation rates and dropout rates to
have continuity of sas numbers meaning
we need to track them all over the state
so when a child leaves a school a public
school or an efa program now or charter
school is responsible for reporting to
the department of education where that
kid went so if the kid said if they said
that the kid went to another public
school in the state of new hampshire and
then we don't see a record for that in
another public school using that same
asset number we will work with the
school to say that kidnap did not show
up when you really need to track that
kid find over there and a lot of times
oh no they went to it they actually went
to a private school or they moved out of
state
um so
in your instance so we would have an
entry code from when the kid enrolled
say in kindergarten kid leaves in second
grade we would have an exit code exit to
homeschool
and then now the child is accessing an
efa there will be a re-entry code that
the scholarship organization will use
and the scholarship organization is is
to the best of their ability ensuring
continuity of sas numbers um so we will
have
the number um
and that same number will be used
throughout them and that's how when we
are looking at the phase out grants or
we're looking at when we had questions i
believe it was last week about how many
kids were in public schools with efa
that's how we were able to do that
because we were able to take the list of
sas numbers that the efa
program has reported to us and look back
in our system for the past 10 years and
say this acid number appeared at any
given time in a public school or or this
asset number is brand new and it's never
appeared in a public school before
so
representative allison
all right thank you mr chair hi caitlin
uh in the past as i remember and it's
getting further and further away uh
height we were having some trouble in
the system
finding those particularly high school
students who left and went somewhere
and and i don't know whether
it was the receiving school wasn't
reporting or what but there was always a
cadre that sometimes grew pretty large
of kids that were in limbo they had left
i mean it was clear they'd left
and but there was not clear
whether they showed up anywhere
particularly in other than new hampshire
school is that still an issue i mean it
could certainly be an issue so our
systems right now um are set up to
to reduce duplication um so if
art ellison were to leave concord high
school and then an art ellison would
show up and conquer in
hopkinton high school with the same date
of birth and name we would say our
system would automatically say are you
sure it's not that same person and then
it would help the schools work together
the system also shows a report to both
concord and to hopkinton saying hey
you know this person looks the same are
you sure it's not the same so that
matching is included but there's always
that risk that a child leaves
and then is not picked up someplace else
and in which case the school
as you
well know this the school would be
would have to count that kid as a
dropout
so and that's how our dropout reporting
works is if if the child is not picked
up and there's no graduation record we
assume that child is a dropout thank you
i i've got a question
is there any tracking of of the
homeschooling youngsters uh in terms of
the unique uh people identifiers so the
only reason we would have information on
a child participating in a homeschool
program is if a child is now receiving
an efa or participating in a class is
class at their public school
so
we there is a small set aside and
adequacy for public schools that are
offering classes to homeschool kids at
the high school level so if if a kid
takes say calculus at their high school
a homeschool kid they would have a sasa
number and they would
report that information back to the
department of education for us to be
able to make that adequacy payment but
other than that there's no tracking for
assassin numbers for home school
children how then do we determine the
adm are
in terms of kids which are in the
district but not in attendance but doing
the homeschooling thing the admr that we
report does not include homeschool or
non-public school children it only
reports only includes kids that are in
public public school or charter schools
or
and we may or we're looking at
potentially including the efa kids in
those reports going forward we actually
had a conversation about it yesterday as
far as reporting and and private schools
if they're a tuition to from a by a
local board to a private school
yeah so if it's a special education
child if it's childhood is just a
regular student if it's a regular
student and it's b the tuition is being
paid by a public school that kid still
shows up as a public school child so
you're talking about a croydon situation
is that well that's exactly right yes
yes so that those would because those
are still counted as public school kids
the state is still paying adequacy on
behalf of those kids and so we would
have that information for those ones but
for a kid that just is enrolled right in
bishop brady high school by their parent
and not participating in an efa we do
not have any information other than
bishop brady has reported that there's
11 11th graders
thank you
uh i i think
represent woodcock had his hand up first
thank you chairman good morning how you
doing hello good good i just i
i think i want to make sure i understood
what you said previously you're talking
about assassin numbers which i have some
familiarity with
but the charter schools you said they
have no assassin numbers i want to show
you the right no assassin numbers
attached no charter schools do have sas
and numbers attached the law does not
specify that charter schools should be
using sas numbers as well although the
department has implemented that for more
than 15 years now so i just wanted when
i was
writing the law for representative
cordelli to add in the scholarship
organizations i was like oh shoot we
should probably include charter schools
too and we put charter schools in but
it's working that way right now it won't
recreate any other work because it's the
exact same thing we don't want to double
pay for a child that is enrolled in a
charter school and a district school or
potentially an efa so that's how we
track all of that information
well thank you yes
yes go ahead thank you just to follow up
good i didn't understand that but thank
you i do now it's much clearer uh in
terms of academic assessments any of
those scores the chart scores do charter
schools report that at all through the
assassin numbers yes okay so charter
schools assess in the same way that
district public schools do
and so what they do is they all public
schools for the purpose of participating
in the state assessment do something
called an aoy in any time of the year
entry and that you is used to roster the
kids we then provide the roster to the
assessment company and the assessment
company then will provide us
scores back for the rosters of the kids
that we're supposed to assess and that's
how we track the kids that did assess
versus the kids that were supposed to
assess and the appropriate grade that
they're assessing in in in their levels
and that's how we do all of our data
reporting well thank you so much thank
you you're welcome uh representative
thank thanks again um uh caitlin thank
you very much mr chair so um you i think
you just mentioned bishop brady yes so
so i'm i i was just wondering if you
could
i'm not sure i followed that i was
wondering if you could talk about how
sas it applies um let's say in a
situation or in a first student that
attends bishop brady for student that
attends st paul's school and for a
student that goes to
let's say pinkerton academy of course so
pinkerton academy assuming that the
child is a resident of dairy and derry
is actually or one of the surrounding
towns that tuitions to pinkerton we do
have student identifiable information
for those children that is because those
kids are receiving adequacy they are
technically public school kids as far as
our systems and whatnot
um if
you were to just tuition your child into
pinkerton and call them a private school
kid a kid from concord that doesn't have
a tuition agreement they would that kid
would not we would not necessarily have
any asset information on that child
as far as saint paul's and bishop brady
we do not collect any personal
identifiable information on those
students um unless the child is
participating in an efa so we do not
have total information so if we know
there's so
let me go back the thing that non-public
schools are required to do is report
once a year to us their enrollment by
grade so if you look on the department
of education website we have reports
that talk about non-public schools and
their enrollment by grade but what we
don't know is in that enrollment by
grade if there's 11 11th graders at
bishop brady how many of those kids
potentially are an efa child versus a
parent paid child but what we do do know
on from on our side of things is if the
kid is a sa is participating in the efa
we have paid for that child so they
could be included in that double account
right now we are not receiving
information from the scholarship
organization as far as where the child
is participating or even if the child is
in in public non-public school or not so
we don't have a way of kind of netting
that out of that number
i i have another now follow-up question
here uh n193e3
there's a requirement for a data
collection regarding the delivery of an
adequate education with these indicators
which way attendance suspension
expulsion yes uh attendance and cte
programs i always mentioned cte uh uh
those and ap courses those going on in
the military et cetera et cetera
is the unique people identifier reflect
that information we can get it in the
aggregate i'm not concerned about the
individual student but i
is this how that's being reported and
gathered yes we we use assassin number
for virtually everything that we're
reporting it's our main thing that we
use to collect and aggregate our data at
the department of education and validate
our data because without the unique
identifier or or any sort of unique um
data collection we would not be able to
uh validate that a kid might not be
included in multiple subgroups or
multiple schools
so that's that is our we have a lot of
validation built into assassin numbers
and so we do have for those college and
career readiness indicators we have a
report that says that caitlyn davis
participated in the sat took the as fab
and
achieved a college and career writing a
cte credential thank you
representative ford you had a question
thank you for taking my question my
concern is with those students who are
caught in the middle of a parental
custody dispute and one of them lives in
one part of the state and the other one
lives in another and each has custody
for a part of the time and the poor kid
in the schools
are caught with how they're delivering
service and if they particularly they
have a specialized program or something
like that it just sounds like a terrible
nightmare for the schools i mean i we
have had conversations with schools
about how that can be a challenge but as
far as the reporting side of things
there are no issues for us
so they can they can in our system
report who is financially responsible
for the child the district that's
financially responsible they can report
that a child is duly enrolled we have
all of those capabilities on the
making sure that the services are
provided and who pays for the services
those are the unfortunately the local
schools need to work through those
situations but on the funding and the
reporting side for the department of
education there are not any challenges
so
it's reported to the department of
education twice a year in october first
and at the end of the year at the end of
the year as an aggregate of what
happened throughout the entire year
so if a child were to move around
multiple times during the year that's
when we would collect that information
at the end of the year that's reported
to the department of education in july
and august
and reconciled through all the different
different systems differing schools can
reconcile that
and our system actually requires that
too so we have a report called the
student too busy report right now and it
will say um hey both concord high school
and hopkinton high school you both
reported caitlyn davis she obviously
didn't go both those schools what
happened and it will you know say oh
well there was some overlap for this
period of time or the service or what
what not so our system does have all
those capabilities right now thank you
very much
uh yes represent cornell
thank you
what happens to this acid number if say
a middle school student this is from
working in a middle school for many
years that the parents withdraw them and
say we're going to florida and we never
get a request for a record and we never
find out what happens
where they where they actually go do
they go anywhere or they could be
sitting so so they um with the school
district will have to withdraw the child
using the appropriate withdrawal code
which is exit to an addition state a
different state um and then that and
there's no additional information past
that date of that withdrawal
okay so this it just goes into like a
thing of they withdrew and that's it
correct okay
so there's no tracking of
we don't have any interstate tracking of
acid numbers or anything like that
sure thanks thanks um um uh
mr chair and and and thanks again and
i'm sorry you you're sort of like being
peppered by them
these are good questions
but i think this is really um
almost uh um you know a learning session
for the uh for the for the committee on
on this um
uh
is there any role for uh for first acid
beyond um secondary
education
i mean it depends on where you want to
track data so um you could track attract
somebody all over the place you can
track them into post-secondary
enrollment you could you could track
them into a employment sort of situation
the department of education does not
collect social security numbers so
anytime you want or and we actually are
prohibited from law to collect and use
social security numbers um so
if you
somebody would need to either say well
to get true mapping of this person
throughout the course of their life
whether it's post-secondary enrollment
or employment or whatnot we would need
to find some sort of unique identifier
to continue on through that situation
so either this asset number or having
the department of education use social
security numbers
and so quick quick follow-up so so
currently none of our the community
college system the university system in
new hampshire do not
use acid numbers um
so i believe they have access assassin
numbers but there's not a lot of um
talking and tracking and whatnot right
now through that it's an area where
there could be improvement but i believe
they do have the authority to use asset
numbers
and the only reason i bring that up is
because that has been discussed as a you
know degree attainment post-secondary
degree attainment has been discussed as
an outcome measure so right now we don't
have information our systems don't tie
together
now many of you probably know the
department of education is undergoing a
robust overhaul of our current system
and we may actually have better
capabilities going forward if that's
something that
were to be required going forward
we're jumping quickly here because we
know you're running short how do we uh
accomplish this audit trail of those who
have access to the
like a superintendent superintendents
are here today and gone tomorrow
and and we're seeing a lot of retirement
going on how do we know that those
people that had access when they leave
no longer have access we lock them out
of our system um so we actually control
all of the access on our system
um and the schools require so
on our side of things so each school has
a person in the system that can allow a
superintendent or a designee in there so
it's a an i4c coordinator we have very
specific trainings around the
requirements of an i4c coordinator um
and then we have on our side of things
our collections that we do about who is
the superintendent and whatnot and that
ties back through our the entire
operation of our system so a
superintendent is required to do a
course size submission a course in class
submission that shows various different
data when that if that course commission
is not done or does not affect the
appropriate superintendent it kicks data
out on other places so we've got it tied
throughout our system
i mean it the one thing that tends to be
is sometimes there can be a lag so if a
superintendent does leave and there's a
report that needs to be submitted the
old superintendent's credentials have
been shut down and then we need to
obviously add a new superintendent in
so
are there further questions i know
caitlyn has to run here a representative
litchfield and then represent woodpark
just quickly thank you first of all um
just quickly
so i can put it in the record um
if the acronyms fasted exactly what is
it state assign student identifier i'm
sorry state assigned student identifier
sas id
represent woodcock thank you just
quickly two simple ones um can another
school who has access to sasser numbers
check assassin's number from a different
school
as far as i am i'm a assassin okay
administrator at school x i want to
check a student at school why who may
come to schoolx
um as far as as
chat i mean you can
you can look up to see if there's a
similar record but you wouldn't be able
to res you wouldn't be able to view any
sort of academic records or anything
like that but you could see if you were
trying to put caitlyn david davis in
this school with this acid number that
it would say oh this kid is already
enrolled in this other school so there
is just as far as duplication of records
but no
confidential information or no academic
information is tied to it at that time
so here's why i can only i can only
review those youngsters who are in my
school
profile
yes
um
as far as academic information yes yeah
okay thank you
can the cte director which also has
those students in his high school
access this asset
yes so the cte director would be
accessing information in kate which is a
subsection of i foresee um and so
there's specific information on those
those kids that are cte kids and
because of the data reporting
requirements that that come with that so
a lot to learn on this
well we're at 9 30 i know you have to
hustle out here and we didn't want to go
over that time i appreciate that i can
be back too for further questions on
this so
sure
i was i was working well past that last
night so
if you guys want to stay i can be here
but thank you well thank you you're
always welcome in this committee we
appreciate it
uh okay we we're still in uh 1626.
um we haven't closed that hearing down
are there any members of the public
which would like to
provide further information i have the
one card and that was from
um caitlin and we will get a card too
from representative bowman introduced it
anybody else not seeing any we're going
to close this down
thank you
coincidentally when she talked and i was
like yeah i didn't make
okay i think we're ready to go ahead
because it is 9 30. uh we're opening up
the hearing now on hb 1649.
this bill is relative to the unique
pupil identification for pupils in in
the education freedom accounts program
it's a continuance of what we were
starting we were discussing with caitlin
welcome representative tanner
thank you mr chair uh for the
record i'm linda tanner i represent
sullivan 9 which includes the towns of
plainfield cornish
grantham
croydon
springfield newport sunapee and unity
it's kind of i think i feel like the
cart came before the horse or whatever
uh we're kind of moving from um
caitlin's maybe six inch view to my 3000
foot view okay
um that's that's how i feel is what's
going to happen with this um
this summer when i was uh debating bills
to put in
um
i had and i was looking through my
statute book and
came up with the unique
pupil identifier section
and my intent with 1649
is to require this sacid or
unique pupil identifier to be given to
each child who is being educated in new
hampshire
using public funding
in order to provide aggregate data to
review the programs and make informed
decisions that's my intent with this
bill
and i worked with ols
uh so we probably were fumbling through
it at the at the same rate
anyway um it's interesting to hear
caitlin's first and then mine um some of
you may not even realize what um a
unique pupil identifier is but it was
set up
to really cover the privacy of
individual students and it's done very
well i think
it's part of a program not just in new
hampshire but across the united states
and
in new hampshire it's supposed to
attract pupils in the new hampshire
system education system
from early childhood programs to
district and then post-secondary
institutions so
at least that's what's in the law
even though they may not do much with it
at the post-secondary level right now
so the
unique pupil identifier protects student
privacy while offering unique student
identifiers to
to gain aggregate aggregate data to
improve the quality accuracy and
reliability of student data the
information is kept in a data warehouse
at the department of education and the
statute again is 195 or 193
e colon 5. so if you want to look that
up
um
since i've been on this committee
i've been concerned with the eligibility
and accountability of our ever extend ex
expanding and extended learning and
voucher programs
since the alternative and extended
learning opportunities were largely
organized implemented and assessed by a
third party agency
namely the scholarship organization
among one of a couple
many students would not have a unique
pupil identifier
data collection would be difficult if
not impossible in these cases and
because of the lack of that unified
tracking system
we couldn't really assess pupil
achievement effectiveness proper
distribution of the public funds
and i feel this system of the unique
pupil identifier
will help us do that
and help us with future decisions
reviews and investigations of these
programs
that would be based on real data
and that could be quantified and and was
subjective
so um i was you know trying to find out
why there were two bills almost exactly
the same going through it seemed that it
should have been sorted out before this
but
um here we are
and
just to give you some slight differences
as caitlyn said there are some slight
differences between the two i didn't
include charter schools because i had no
idea that they were not included
in statute because they're always you
know yesterday all day we heard they
were public schools okay
um
and
my bill uh speaks to uh the efa accounts
whereas i believe the
only talks about the scholarship
organization
and since the scholarship organization
has never put in an rfp
and there's also a giving and going
alliance that
distributes some of these educational
freedom accounts or tax credits accounts
um
i felt that it needed to be in the in
the statute so that um
in the future if another organization or
even if the state decided um
to take over the job that now the
scholarship organization has
um and take back the 10 percent that the
scholarship organization
uh makes off the top of those uh
scholarships that uh it would be good to
um have a wider statement in the
law
uh the last thing i think that is
different
is if you look at the last page of of my
bill 14
you'll notice that there's um
on page 3
line
i've also put in a new paragraph
under the educa education freedom
accounts
scholarship organization authority and
responsibilities
um so it's amending
rsa 194-f
colon 4 and it inserts the following
paragraph that the scholarship
organization
shall request and maintain unique pupil
identifiers pursuant to 193 e5
which shall be kept to aggregate data
reported to the department of education
to certify student eligibility because i
was concerned that
we would have students take the efa
and then either use it out of state or
move out of state and there would be no
way for
the state of new hampshire to track that
and i'm not sure how the scholarship
organization has set up to track things
to
residency age
income and determine the enrollment
status with resident schools
to record annual record records of
attainment
to report qualifying expense records and
to determine
compliance with the rules and
requirements and i i've also made this
effective 60 days after passage whereas
the other bill is effective on passage
um
there's one other thing i wanted to
mention
with that too
but i hope i'll think about it and
maybe come up with it so but that's
basically why they're different i i
think they can easily
be
connected together uh and main because i
think the intent
certainly from the department of
education that wrote the the first bill
is that they they realized that they
needed this
to track the efa people as well because
of the adequacy payments um
and uh so i think the the need is there
there's no question about that is
probably a little bit in the wording and
delivery of it
so i'm open for questions thank you very
much uh represent luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative tanner for
bringing this um forward um there uh
there certainly seems to be a lot of
similarity between um 1626 and in 1649
as you've as you've clearly
laid out here i was wondering if you
could comment a little bit more on
on what you see is the difference
between the the term that you're using
in 1649
called quote scholarship organization
for the distribute distribution of efas
and
the term
it used in 1626 which is scholarship
organization yeah just and i think i i
tried to mention this before but
uh just to put a pin in it is that the
scholarship organization that's
currently in place has never had an rfp
with the state
and was set up to do the tax credit
scholarships
which did not use supposedly public
funding
but now it's using public funding
through adequacy
and
hopefully they'll have an rfp coming up
but there may be other scholarship
organizations
that will
eventually
or might take over this particular task
and certainly the giving and going
alliance which is still active
which gives scholarships to christian
schools
uh is part of this mix as well and so i
think
for the distribution of efas
is an important
uh preposition to the scholarship
organization so it isn't just
the current scholarship organization
yes follow up on that so um when you put
down for the distribution of efas
would that specifically exclude then a
scholarship organization that's um
that's managing the the tax credit um
scholarships
not if they're if they are um
distributing the efas then they're the
scholarship organization right now so
they would be
these the scholarship organization is
listed here excuse me if for example
next year
liberty mutual decided that they were
going to be the scholarship organization
to distribute these efa funds um then
they would still fit this particular
bill i think in the other bill
it wouldn't be it isn't as expansive
okay thank thank you very much uh
represent tanner i have a question um
throughout um our our conversation i'm
meaning the committee and what what
you've got in
law right here especially on page three
where you've added the new paragraph you
talk about aggregate data reported
aggregate aggregate and
if i'm a
school principal
of data i oftentimes would
access this assassin information
looking for individual student data in
terms of attendance
previous behavior suspension expulsion
et cetera
so uh
i just want to make sure that we're not
always talking aggregate data which i
know what that is and you know what that
is and what it's used for for you know
delivery of an instruction meeting all
those indicators for meeting delivery of
an adequate education yes
but
is there not this other purpose that we
have this set up to provide
a person like who is a high school
principal like mr woodcock over here
that information about a student might
be enrolled or has been enrolled in
his or her school
thank you for the question um i think
i think the this bill that i've
introduced doesn't change what uh
representative woodcock if he was
principal of an elementary school i
believe um
high school was a high school okay um
what he would want to get it doesn't
change that at all the the last
paragraph speaks just to the efas into
the scholarship organization and every
time
i've asked for any information from the
scholarship organization
i've been
well informed
that they are not allowed to give out
individual
information nor are they
they're in
they are very um
very uh
focused on confidentiality and not
releasing anything but aggregate data so
that's why in that particular one
that particular paragraph
which doesn't apply
to this asset for
our
regular school districts are from
childhood education up to post-secondary
it only applies
to
194-f colon 4 which is the
education freedoms accounts scholarship
organization authority and
responsibility yeah
thank you
further questions
yes representative moffitt
thank you ms chairman thank you for
taking my question
on page the page that says page two at
the top
if you go down to
lines 15-16 set question on that
it says the information maintaining the
data warehouse shall be available to the
department of education that's in
statute but you add
i'm sorry you add the legislative budget
office and the attorney general's office
so
my question is um
why couldn't those two new other
officers just ask doe for the
information in other words the
the
intent of the student identifier number
is to try to protect the privacy of the
students so the more places we push this
information out to
the greater the chance that there might
be a leak or something so so why were
the attorney general's office and
why would you want to send this
information there
um thank you for the question i think uh
caitlyn davis answered that and the fact
that she recognized it was there and
said that um they actually do
would have access to it because they are
an agency of the state and they are
um you know a confidential agency it
would be only in instances where they
would have to do a review now the lba
is responsible for the oversight of the
scholarship committee
and the attorney general's office would
be involved if there was any fraud in
that particular program that's why as
just uh the like i said from the 3000
foot level from a person who didn't have
access to a lot of information
um writing this bill um
thought that it would be important to
put that in
follow-up yes
so i guess my follow-up question is
for the protection of the data again as
i said before the more places it goes to
the greater the chance of leaking why
couldn't the attorney general's office
or the legislative budget office just go
to doa if they needed to
and and ask for them
ask them for the information rather than
having it pushed to them okay well i
guess i guess my other concern with that
um and i i totally see your question and
it may not even be necessary to put that
in if that's that's your point on that
that was caitlyn's point that these
people already have access to that
my concern has been that we have not
gotten a lot of data from the department
of education and when we have some of it
has not been
uh totally accurate like uh the physical
note for
the uh efas in the first place which has
gone from
120 000 to 68 million dollars now
so
um you know i want to make sure
personally i wanted to make sure that
these agencies which are responsible for
some oversight to this third
party agency that's now involved with
our state education programs
um
have the ability to seek this data and
that it's in statute
i i might follow a little bit on that
um
the
attorney general's office and the
legislative budget office uh especially
the lba
has authority to do a performance audit
on any aspect of our educational systems
in this state
there was a performance audit that was
just requested representative mullen you
were a participant on that where we're
looking for a performance audit in terms
of special education
and
when they are tasked to do that by this
legislature we have that authority to do
then they don't need to go to doe
begging saying hey we're trying to have
access to this particular system to do
this performance audit whether they have
it or not they need it
um so that they can complete their tasks
and so we can get the information
as quickly as possible
i think the other the other thing to
note though is that the scholarship
organization if they
they feel this fraud um they're supposed
to
alert the attorney general's office and
the lba and then those two
groups actually do the actual audits um
and again it just i thought i felt it
would be more secure
to have it in statute um that that they
were able to
get this information so
thank you both
yeah the
lba is a huge office it's the few staff
we have in this building is just the
edge
um there's a huge office there that does
these performance audits and it's been
we've been very fortunate to have some
really good performance audits done for
us in the past which have netted us
information to go further with
legislation
so thank you are there other questions
for
representative tanner
maxine thank you very much thank you now
we have cards here do we
yes
technical help from matt southerland if
we have questions or if you have
something to offer us
welcome
good morning again matt southerton with
children's scholarship fun
i wish
kaitlyn was here i'm not going to be
able to do her justice she would be able
to explain this better than i
uh i believe we're talking about sasid's
and the i4c system
i do want to mention a couple points
in the law that you're discussing today
uh section and it says that i'm not sure
if she went over this with you or or not
but the commissioner does
have the power to allow anyone to to go
into this acid system so i'm not sure
if you really need to
you know give us explicit authority or
not since the commission already has
that but i really want to talk about the
technical points of this last paragraph
that you just discussed
there are certain abilities that the i4c
system has and then it doesn't have
the i4c system does allow us to check
student enrollment and we also use the
sas system with the unique pupil
identifier number to upload to the doe
database
for the ois and the boys
what it would not allow us to do
is it would not allow us to put
financial data in there
as it s as as it appears that you would
like us to do
and it simply doesn't have that
capability
it also would not allow us to
put in data to say comply with program
rules
we do
our contract does require us to
um
report aggregated student assessment
data once a year so we do do that
and i believe that that is in the i4c
system
uh
the sasa does collect unique pupil id
numbers in the data doa database but it
doesn't have residency data attached to
it so we couldn't use it for that
i think that i went through all of the
and we do obviously we do collect income
data
i don't believe that that is in the i4c
system although we do use the i4c system
obviously
in conjunction with department of
education for them to award the grants
for free and reduced lunch
so
just wanted to make those points
are there any questions
so
in terms of the assessment data
uh this statewide performance tool
um
aggregate data versus individual data
exactly aggregated data non-identifying
so
so the your organization's going to
throw in that we are
the enrollment in this school is at the
55th percentile or
you're not going to know exactly where
individual students are in fact that the
commissioners looking to find out you
know
looking at a specific attendance issue
and discipline issue also wanting to
look at achievement and growth um that's
not going to be available uh i'm i pro i
can't answer that right now i would have
to go back and
okay get more detail for you
further questions
now c thank you very much thank you
we have no other pink cards up here so
we're going to close this hearing thank
you
yep five minutes
or a little bit more
seven
i'll turn my mic on so
knowing we're streaming
uh 1295 is a bill requiring reports
concerning school policies on classroom
recordings and in classroom observers
and represent moffat is the prime
sponsor of the bill uh representative
moffat is here welcome
thank you mr chair and you notice the
chair just said uh we're going live
we're streaming and i'm going to come
back to that
for the record uh
i'm state representative mike moffatt
representing merrimack district 9 which
includes the lovely town of canterbury
which features shaker village and also
the lovely town of loudoun which
features howard pearl's maple syrup
so
this measure is a reprise by the way i
did
email everyone this uh a draft for this
testimony last night
so this measure is a reprise of last
year's hb 321 which is now law
hb 321
simply asked if you recall that school
districts share what if anything
they were doing to identify and support
gifted students
for best practices folder at the
department of education and early
indications are that the gifted measure
that is passed
and is now off
is getting a very good response the
school districts all over the state are
now having internal discussions on how
to better support that previously
underserved student population
and with no policy mandate or spending
requirement so
some of us see that as a real success
story and we'd like this to emulate that
so hb 1295 similarly asks school
districts to simply share their
classroom observation policies as well
as audio visual audio video streaming
and recording policies with the doe
for another best practices folder
virtual folder
so attention to this area became
important during the
ongoing i was going to say recent but
the ongoing covid pandemic
when so many schools went to hybrid
instruction
and remote instruction
some schools went totally remote nashua
for example closed its doors for over a
year
so remote learning raised new questions
in numerous areas to include technology
issues
cost issues access issues privacy issues
legal issues and more
what about homes that do not have
internet access or families that don't
have computers
and then there's the issue of recording
if a
student misses an online session
what are the ramifications of he or she
viewing your recorded version later on
and are schools making provisions for
recording and saving such sessions
and i would point out as i touched on
earlier when the chair mentioned
streaming um our committee hearings are
being recorded the same on youtube um
presumably in perpetuity or forever
uh
as as i speak as we're here
in fact there's a camera right there
looking at me and i would say hello to
the people watching live however many
there are and also
to the people from the future again
these all of our sessions are recorded
and they're on youtube i've gone back
and looked at pieces a few of them 20
years ago somebody
may call this very
uh session up and to see what our what
our discus what the bill
how the bill was introduced and
how we dealt with it and these folks
from the future will know if it passed
they'll know who the president nominated
for supreme court or if tom brady ever
retired so people from the future
will see
what we have what we're putting out
there to include this very moment
but these hearings differ from classroom
sessions of course many high school and
college students record
or seek to record lectures for future
study and review purposes
uh teachers and professors typically
include recording protocols in their
syllabi and i used to
most syllabi have a section for
recording policies
at the discretion of the individual
professor or or teacher
um
but educators who don't mind their
lectures being recorded sometimes have
issues with ubiquitous cell phones so
take taping policies sometimes conflict
with recording policies for example
cell phones here's mine
if a
teacher or professor has a policy that
cell phones can't be deployed
that might be in conflict with their
recording policy where they say yes you
can record my uh my lectures or whatever
so anyway that's that type of thing in
this brave new world uh
needs some attention
so that's why a best practices folder in
this area could be very useful
in the same way that the best practices
folder has turned out to be
useful regarding gifted students and
that
that was hb 321 which is now law
and then there is the
classroom observer issue which is part
of this measure
when i was classroom teacher i'd
occasionally get requests from parents
to sit in
didn't happen often but it occurred
but classrooms can only accommodate so
many visitors of course like you know
this room can only accommodate so many
visitors although this can
this room can accommodate a lot more
visitors than a typical classroom
so
in their administrative classroom visits
for the purposes of teacher evaluations
they announced or unannounced varies
from district to district
so
again with classroom visits
presumably
district schools have policies on if a
parent or a board member or
anybody wants to sit in a class it's
different now because it's there are
more security measures in terms of
classroom visitations
um
and this bill doesn't is not
prescriptive it doesn't
have any any policy party just is asking
what's what's being done out there again
for a best practices folder
um
when i taught high school many years ago
few had ever heard of the internet i
guess it existed but you know
we didn't know that it didn't it was
very small but nowadays
uh it's it's everywhere
so for remote classes nowadays you know
who can tune in uh what's happening
right now
i don't suspect there's a vast audience
but
anybody who's on youtube can hear my
voice now
and they can as i said earlier they can
go back and listen to it later
so what if a parent wants to watch a uh
high school class
or in this in the last year and a half
almost two years
um
when school many schools went to hybrid
or remote you know that raises some
concerns about you know who's watching
these classes can parents watch can
others watch you know the interactive uh
questions that that really need some
attention
um what if the link to a class is is
shared widely uh are there you know
passwords to get in
probably uh will it be on youtube
forever what if what if there's an open
mic uh situation as this happened um
in the legislature several times
what if what if a student um does
something embarrassing
uh makes a mistake is that going to be
out there forever on youtube
or
if it's not on youtube and a lot of
these high school or
school remote sessions were not
necessarily on youtube it maybe would
not even be being recorded unless what
if surreptitiously a family a parent a
student of somebody
records a
classroom session
you know
how do you control that again i i don't
know those are questions that
need attention
many of us think
so i don't have answers only questions
this bill would help create that virtual
folder which would provide some answers
alternatives options
and information
um
and i will say that uh represent
representative hobson and i had a
session with the commissioner uh caitlin
davis was there a couple other officials
from boe just to talk about several
measures including this one doe
with regard to the gifted bill which
again is law they have sent out a
template and they have a process to
accept and receive this information that
is now being talked about
um all over the state forget you know
for gifted students um
you know taking care of them same thing
here they if this were to move forward
or some version of this would move
forward so that they could have another
virtual folder or best practices folder
so that people can see
and compare what's being done what the
issues are what the concerns are is they
see a need for it
i see a need for it
um
so
and yes this could uh the question comes
up you know why do we need a statue
can't do we like put out a memo or rules
and ask for this and that could be done
but again as with other measures like
the gifted measure if something's in
statute if it has the imprimatur of
legislative concern or interest
if it's a law
it matters it matters a lot if something
is a statute as opposed to a memo or a
rule
so um
that is about it and again i would again
state and emphasize to finish this up
that this requirement could in many
cases simply be satisfied
with the gifted bill again which is the
model for this you know there are
concerns it's an unfunded mandate or
it's going to we need to send the
schools money so they can implement this
or hire people whatever
and again
this
requirement shouldn't move forward could
probably in many cases be
answered or responded to in a few in a
minute
an administrative assistant or a
secretary could just send an email with
a link or an attachment of their of
policies to doe so they could file it
and in many cases as with the gifted
bill many schools had nothing going on
for for gifted students and so their
response was we're not doing anything in
this area same with this um
we don't see it at all is it an onerous
administrative uh unfunded mandate
just as you know again
an email with an attachment or if if
this is an impetus for local discussion
on this issue that maybe would be useful
and should happen that that's up to the
district if they if they want to
dive down and dig into this
if no policies exist regarding recording
or visitation issues then the this
measure again as i said would could
provide that impetus so that's
what 1295 is about and i'd be happy to
take any questions if there are any
thank you very much questions
thank you very much mr chair and um and
good to see you this morning
representative moffatt um i was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about
what you i guess have been able to find
or not
able to find
online with regards to
either best practices or
or
you know guidance from either the state
or federal
departments of education numerous other
organizations education commission of
the states and csl
with respect particularly to classroom
recording
and remote learning given so much has
been done uh in this area over the last
couple years sure that's a great
question um and to answer it i've done a
cursory uh google search on on you know
some of the if you google classroom
recording policies you know all kinds of
things will come up
um so i've done it like i said a cursory
very
you know simple search to just get a
sense of you know what is out there i'm
always interested in what other states
are doing and again
there's not much in statute because this
is this this issue of hybrid or remote
high school and in public school classes
is a new phenomenon really going back to
you know covert is less than
it's really less than two years old so
uh i've done a little bit but i
will and want to do more and i i think
that if this moves forward whether it
moves or not districts i think need to
pay attention to this and come up with
some policies
um but no i haven't i haven't done a
thorough comprehensive uh
analysis of what's out there yet but but
this
uh i think would help that to occur um
if this virtual folder
was established a doe
then they would
have
all kinds of stuff coming in that they
could look at or not and again
there's no requirement here for doe to
process the information simply to
warehouse it if you will
and with gifted um they
are already
have a template or a folder in place now
if whether it's gifted or this bill if
doe
evaluated on their own time if they
wanted to or someone else
if one of us or whoever wanted to go to
d-o-e-d-o-e
and see what's come in and uh see see
things that have never been thought
about before perhaps some
possible
proposed statute might come out of that
i have nothing in mind at this time but
to gather this information one spot and
then have somebody evaluate mainly to
identifying something that needs
attention in statute maybe
a long answer but hopefully that
you know
the questions represent woodcock
thank you chairman
president good morning
and i don't think tom's gonna retire
this year
um
that that being said uh as far as the
your policy have you had a chance uh to
speak with the school boys association
in terms of their policy templates that
they work with all the school boys on as
regards these issues
i have not yet uh
i see i say unfortunately there's not
too many folks here
but another great question uh no i have
not um get into anything with the school
board association
that is something that would maybe
happen if there was a specific policy
measure that was proposed and this
this is not a policy measure it's not a
spending measure it's just a you know
gathering information measure so uh
again great great question i'm sure i'm
sure they would be very interested in
this
uh but again this is just a
measure to gather information not to
push any specific statute
thank you i asked that because it seems
to me that there's two
uh
clearly different uh pieces of this
policy
one would be the standard incl you call
it observer there's classroom visitor
policy which i'm sure most schools
already have and the school association
probably has templates for it and then
of course the streaming one um so
there's like two distinct things the the
traditional in classroom i'm sure all
the schools have that just for safety
[Music]
so the second part of the question is as
i read the end of the statute request it
talks about initial time frames of
initial presentation or
information reported back to the
commissioner and then it has followed up
with any subsequent changes uh november
one
so if if school board x replies that
here's our policies and link link link
they have on file right
and they make no changes so there's no
more they're done
next november the following it's just a
one-time shot until such a point that
they change their policy is that how you
interpret that correct yes okay all
right thank you thank you chairman
represent tanner
thank you and i don't think tom's going
to retire right now
um
and i hope not actually i love watching
him um what i'm wondering is and you
were you were on a school board uh for a
while and thank you for doing that uh
that's
quite a job
um
do you see that
this particular
request
has a legal ramification to it
that the gifted and talented didn't
okay
i always tell my students to repeat the
question what's in your question so the
question was
do
do i see this as having legal
ramifications uh
that the gifted measure did not
yeah thank you for your question uh
interesting question and i think i think
you may be onto something i i i think
that the gifted bill
uh simply asked
for what are you doing and let us know
what you're doing i think this is
different i think i think you're onto
something i think that
given the world wide web and and uh you
know the internet there are certainly
potential
uh privacy issues that
they would have legal ramifications that
would be part of this
so coming out of this um
yes i think that that this measure would
definitely
um potentially involve some legal issues
that um just weren't part of the gifted
bill
yes
excuse me
so i think
in the past it seems to me that we had
people here and and there was some
and i'm not sure where it is in the
statues maybe uh attorney fenton can
kind of
gear me to that area about surveillance
in schools
and about the you know the ability of
people to come in and hack
i'm also concerned
that a teacher may want to copyright
their lecture
or
that some parent who has heard on
some
talk radio that their local school has
crt and now wants to
view all the videotapes from
the history class to make sure you know
that they haven't brought up some nasty
subjects or something that they don't
want
and i feel like these are legal issues
and i feel like they're local control
issues and i feel like yes it's probably
good to put it out there to school
boards and to parents and to teachers
organizations
that um
you know the commissioner is is thinking
of this but i also think it's um
opening pandora's box to have
something like a repository first
and and the legal things
second i think we're kind of putting the
cart before the horse again
with this bill and i was wondering if
you could see
some of these issues might be
really
pretty profound
given that there'd be a repository at
the at the commissioner's office in the
department of ed
yeah thank you for your question i
actually kind of feel the
kind of the opposite position i think
that you make some points like for
example i hadn't thought necessarily
about surveillance but uh surveillance
videos or cameras are every they're
ubiquitous they're everywhere today i
didn't even thought of that
um
but
the the notion of a
a repository or or
a folder that just has
existing policies that are already
public just putting them in one bigger
folder for the convenience of someone
who wants to look into them i think that
that
obviously i think that's a good thing
you mentioned copywriting lectures again
um
i know
some classes are different i know
so uh a p
i know people who just
uh taped every
anatomy physiology lecture and then
played them over and over and studied
all the bones and stuff that that type
of thing um
the notion of some lectures being
copyrighted uh
that very interesting um and again this
measure has no zero uh stats
there's no statutory policy
proposal whatsoever there's no spending
proposal again
it's just a
request to gather information that might
be useful to have one one place
in my view
thank you very much i i have a uh just
pursue one of the areas that was asked
of you
several years ago the representative
sits to my right
put in a bill very similar to this
dealing with
videos and audio being taken place in a
classroom
it passed legislation i went in the law
and within a year there was so much
controversy the whole thing had to be
rebaked
um so i i i asked a question if you
haven't
talked with the school boards
association
they conducted a number of training
sessions following this fiasco
and
policies were developed
so that the school districts and schools
internally within
can
deal with the issues of confidentiality
deal with the issues of special
education
deal with all those issues dealing with
family life
and the idiot the all the
uh areas that and the ramifications of
that that can up and end up in the
courtroom which are very very real
so um you're asking that this developed
policies may be submitted
would you not think it's a good idea
that we first
go and check and find out what the has
as a result of that
you know affair we went through find out
what policies are placed
and then move forward
yeah thank you for the question carmen i
think that's exactly what this bill the
intent of this bill is is to uh you know
see what's out there what's what's done
what's been done uh what the issues are
um i know initially with the gifted bill
uh there was a tendency for some to get
down in the weeds and say what about
this or we define this or about this and
and that bill
finally which is now law
um
i i kept saying we the intent of that
bill or this bill is not to get down in
the weeds uh like i'm hearing a little
bit here about what about
previous statues and previous
experiences this bill proposes nothing
in the way of policy nothing in the way
of spending we don't want to get down in
the weeds we just the intent of this is
just simply to
facilitate
sharing of
issues best practices policies
approaches concerns in a central
location for anyone to look at
so i think the intent of this kind of
answers your question about uh
looking at my follow-up question to you
uh is that
what you're asking for was the result of
that process that we went through and
the to gather policies come up with
policy which would respect we had for
example instructors coming out of the
post-secondary institution wanting to
take
pictures of of kids
the student teachers in the classroom
but then there was the issue that we had
one student in the classroom that had an
iep and that you know was confidential
information
and and and how that was being done at
that
so then that kind of puts a wrinkle on
that all these
issues were taken into account and
policies were the result so i would
encourage you to
talk with the school boards association
and find out
obtain those policies and the process
that went through i sat in a many many
of those meetings over there were all
districts were participating in
communicating and trying to come up with
a a
what you're trying to do here is come up
with what's the best practice for
policies i think that's already out
there but you know it's up to you to
pursue but i would encourage you please
to
contact them
yeah yeah thank you mr chair for that
question and comment and again as i said
earlier you know whatever happened uh
a year and years ago
preceded the covid uh the covid pandemic
so this
is a this is prompted largely by the
covert pandemic which is new
and again
i emphasize um that the intent of this
is not to get into any specific issue
at all
the intent of this as i said a couple of
times is just to
gather or what's out there and no
district needs to uh
you know
share anything if they don't want to i
it's a it's a request
for doe to establish a folder and and
ask request
policies that districts are willing to
to share we don't want to get into any
at this point we just want information
we don't want to touch on any specific
uh thing other than
to ask schools to share with what they
what they have represented ellison
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh specifically on the
classroom observer policies
you talked about kind of
what would be included in that uh i
guess i understand the the sort of the
way
a policy that a school district has
might
relate to general the general public or
to parents
you also seem to include
classroom observer
policies that relate to teacher
evaluation i mean every every single
school district and a lot of this is
written in the contract as there will be
x number of visits by your
administration and the first year
teachers will get this and the third
year teachers will get that you you
really want all that information from
every single school district put into
this file sure i think in my comments
that i put out to everybody uh i might
have mentioned in in terms of observers
um
every school is different uh some have
more in the way of definition policies
than others and representative wood
caucus i keep hearing you as a principal
and i've been out there too so
in terms of classroom observation uh
that's not part of the the bill it's
very brief but my comments to you all to
or my testimony with regard to classroom
observers
i just pointed out that uh principals i
believe you know are expected
to observe teachers
uh so they announced visits or
unannounced uh that's what somebody had
mentioned to me when we were working on
the language
the reason that we tie in the observer
piece of this
in the actual 1295
is that
in terms of
observing classes
we're in a a new world i don't know if
it's a brave new world but um
if classes through the pandemic have
been observed by parents remotely
then the question comes up
you know once we hopefully get back to a
classroom
uh
you know brick and mortar building
classroom type deal and it's no longer
remote some parents uh may have enjoyed
or been pulled in or care about the
instruction and some of them i know
miss
uh
the chance to see what
what the classes are doing and so some
of them if they want to visit in person
uh as a practical matter you know you
can only have so many and again we're
not suggesting any policy but if
if like what's happening here
um
perhaps
if schools can afford to or if there's
certain classes that uh more
amenable to recording
uh
you know should this happen in class
classes i i don't know i am that's the
type of information that i think d.o.e
and others are interested in
what's out there what's being done um
does that kind of address your question
hopefully
follow up thank you
just so i'm clear
it would be your expectation or you
would hope
that every school district would provide
its policies for classroom observation
by administrators for determining tenure
for teachers whether they're going to be
rehired because that's that seems to me
comes under classroom observer policy
sure yeah i thank you for the question
uh again um i left my bill over there at
my notes here but uh the the bill does
doesn't
yeah
in terms of uh teacher evaluation that
type of observation the bill doesn't get
into that at all
uh
it's a very broad uh bill just asking
what policies are out there for
observation
in my again in my comments to you i just
threw out that
some parents want to sit in
uh
administrators i think are supposed to
at some point do an announcement or an
unannounced visit that's not part of the
bill that's just stuff that's out there
that
that is part of
the
classroom observer issue
but that's not part of the the bill just
again just
asks what's what's being done and and um
let us know
what you're doing and
if you would so that we can have that
best practices folder to
to look at represent thank you
thank you chairman
brother i just have a couple of
follow-ups a moment ago in the i'm sure
the youtube tape that's been recorded
we'll document this uh you said that all
they're trying to do is you would just
ask the superintendents what they had
and they could send it in
your bill on line four says they shall
it's not a question just ask
superintendent what are you doing it
says they shall do it the superintendent
which is distinctly different than just
asking if it's okay to do it which is
sort of the impression you gave at least
from my assumption as i listen to you
dialogues that concerns me
the second one is um
and i'm sure almost every every school
i've been involved with has a
a boilerplate it's not a hand-crafted
policy that deals with
visitors in the building visiting the
classroom et cetera et cetera
i'm concerned
and
i wouldn't i wouldn't use the word
devious because i don't think that's the
type of person you are but i'm concerned
at least not generally but i'm concerned
that this is a backdoor
reference to a lot of the dialogue that
we heard of the committee last week
earlier this week as regards school
boards and limitations and parents and
visitations and access
and i hope that that's not what this is
but that but that raises my concern just
because of the timing
yeah sure
thank you represent woodcock for your
two questions the first one had to do
with with shao yes again to my earlier
points about this being statute and from
the legislature uh to to show that this
is something that needs attention and
so yes that's why we want something in
statute
and in terms of visitor policies uh
again there is no proposal here and you
make the great point that these visitor
policies presumably i'm sure exist in
most schools and if if there are some
schools that don't have a visitor policy
or they don't have a good one or they
need to update one if this measure
provides some impetus for a few schools
to pay to look at something that needs
attention and that
i think is a good thing um in terms of
uh you know a nefarious intent
again you have a lot of the language
there it's like the gifted bill it's
very short i consider it sweet uh just a
way to um engage
uh
school districts on what i think what
many of us think is an area that just
needs some attention and
discussion and and
again no specific uh agenda or policy
piece other than to just get this on
people's school districts radar screens
uh like we thought the gifted
issue should be more on more radar
screens and now it is and i think many
many good things are coming from that
and again i know i keep comparing the
two but one template the initial
template i think is the same template
for this i think the gifted measure
put that on radar screens and a lot of
good is coming from that and i see we
see a need for this to get some
attention and by having a modest statue
just creating a folder i think
would do that
quickly just a comment thank you
i would say
schools
particularly after the multiple
shootings across the country
in the last decade have done a vigorous
job and an in-depth job of preparing
visitor
policies in classroom policies to
respond to that sure so i'm sure that
there there are plenty available thank
you mr chairman very much
are there reps on nelson another
principal
thank you mr chairman as a former
principal and a special ed teacher and a
regular aid teacher
this i don't know all the background on
this i apologize for that but i think
from a teacher point of view the issues
that i ran as a special ed teacher in
the classroom that needed to be
addressed
that you would never do if there was a
camera going
indeed some student just says one little
thing and you know you need to have to
talk to them later or confidentially
that concerns me
and
as a health in other words would they
record a health bed question that's
another one teacher was talking about
sex ed
would you want a camera in that when a
student may ask a question that would be
embarrassing would students be quiet and
so i can't ask anything our kids are
going to make fun of me you got a
question
good point thank you
would i would i believe that
thank you representative uh yes uh
you know excellent points and and i
again i go back to what's happening here
uh with representative nelson's
questions and with representatives
questions representing
ellison's questions and and
representative tanner's questions and
representative vlad's questions and
uh that's the intent of this is to
promulgate or or
provide some impetus to address some of
these things i don't have a position i
have no positions on any of those issues
other than you know i think it would be
useful to uh
bring those forward and if there are
existing special ed policies in terms of
what you describe
uh
some schools may have them some may not
some have different ones
again i i see some of us see of great
value to uh d.o.e having a a place to
that
that someone can go to
uh who wants to see what's out there
what's being done what works what
doesn't and uh i think only good things
can happen when we share
best practices or bad practices that
didn't work and just
you know again i
in terms of getting in the weeds and
your specifics that's not where
where i'm at
just looking for a folder thank you very
much um
well we're okay okay
thank you who's your intended audience
for going to look for this information
other superintendents
question was uh who is the intended
audience for for going looking at this
information uh
there is no intended audience per se um
i think who would this potentially be
who would this potentially be of
interest to
i think it would be of interest to
school boards i think would be of
interest to administrators i think it
could be interested of interest to
parents potentially if the interest
of interest to legislators may be
if they get
constituent
queries or requests for
legislation in some some areas related
to observation or audio visual recording
to know that
there's a place that they could go to
that that d.o.e has that they could uh
could refer to does that can you answer
your question hopefully yeah i just if a
constituent asked me i would go to my
superintendent
thank you very much representative
moffett uh i don't see any more hands so
uh
thank you very much and i don't have any
other pink cards on this particular
topic so we're going to close this
hearing thank you
i did look it up so it's three support
and for 40 opposed
jesse
marjorie is not here
okay
so uh where we are on our docket for
today we've gone through the three bills
that were on the top of it uh the two
bills which are
uh were there are now been postponed to
a time to be announced
and so uh we're gonna take a break uh
until
one o'clock where we have to pick this
up again
uh there will be various uh not no the
committee will not have any work
sessions because none of that's been
posted identified uh several of us are
going to join though and try to do some
administrative work
so with that uh
take a break be a long lunch
you
okay it is uh one o'clock and we're
going to go ahead with the next round of
bills which we have to hear this
afternoon
the first bill on the docket for one
o'clock here is hb
that's relative to the best interest of
the student for a change of school or
assignment
and the prime sponsor is not here today
so we're having represent boom introduce
the bill
thank you mr chairman for the record
ralph bowm
hillsborough district 20
town of litchfield
and this bill is like said relative best
into the student for a change of school
assignment
it's fairly simple
line
four it says a
student's school or assignment the
superintendent shall consider consider
parental concerns
and the students academic physical so
parental concerns was added
and then line 13
it says or do students transfer to a
public school or public academy in the
state of new hampshire so those are the
changes to current law which is 193
colon 3 1 e and f
so
that's pretty much it
thank you very much
are there any other people that have
pink cards for this um are there any
questions for represent boom i'm sure
you know he's not the author of the
yes represent ford
i'm just asking naively
does this affect them how are they
adjusted for it
when you specify in new hampshire
the new hampshire students in new
hampshire public schools but i mean if
one of those new hampshire schools is
going across to maine or someplace like
that
is there any adjustment for that
i don't believe if they're in a
at school in another state then they're
not
i don't know how that works it might be
in the area of agreement that they have
just my ignorance
mine too
i i i just can give you a a would
believe would you believe that we do
have schools that are approved schools
in the state
that that are approved schools
that
are not located in this state
i'm referencing the
schools in fairly vermont which are part
of the school district which is an inter
state
school district
so it's possible that a superintendent
could place the kids in an elementary
school in fairly vermont
um
i i don't know why not i don't know if
this legislation allows that
and i'm i'm looking to see if it says
public school
transfer to another public school
within the district residence
so it means somebody
in the budding school district and would
you believe that would be the the person
in the budding district like the one i'm
living in right now which
it has been done in the past
uh could that occur now i don't know
yeah but the new the item number four
says the student transfer public school
or public academy in the state of new
hampshire so
i would think in that case what you
mentioned it probably could put it to
another public school in new hampshire
rather than in in
i understand
okay yeah i don't know we don't get a
debate going on here right now
woodcock
thank you chairman i'm looking at uh
item four as representative
bowman just identified
and it seems to me
the preceding
line item 3 on lines 11 and 12
says exactly the same thing
except for it limits to new hampshire
and that would then
exempt the school that you're talking
about on the board of states
yes if the
district yes my question is why would
you want to refer for a continuous town
like
up north or havel or down south by where
all the
schools are on the rockingham county or
up north
that's not your bill i don't know i
don't know i mean the thing is line
three is different than line four nine
three is
an approved school in another district i
don't see that much different between
line three and four myself
if i may
yeah line four just specifies that it
has to be in the state right without
line four then representative ladd
concerned for a contiguous sound over
the border would be okay
so this this eliminates the opportunity
to move uh approve school
well except it says or so i don't even
know why this line is in here
because the previous line
does cover another district in the state
of new hampshire so and since it says or
not and
you know
the line three still exists and line
three covers everything that would be
covered in line four
for purposes of the committee right now
i have no other pink cards in this
and so we're really talking amongst
ourselves and that's okay we'll allow
that to happen seeing that prime
sponsor's not here maybe we can save a
little time if we start to talk this
thing out a little bit
and and and maybe uh can you know each
of us come to some you know idea where
we are on it
so let's just open it up for just
general discussion
i don't see anybody back there that's
got a pink car so
so representative mullen
so it looks to me like if we add four
we're actually adding a restriction
rather than
opening it up it was open
in
number three
right transfer to public school public
academy or
private school in another district
yes period so that could be new
hampshire that could be vermont that
could be maine
can i so why do we need i guess my
question is why do we need to specify
new hampshire
in number four
it still doesn't resolve the interstate
district
or interstate governmental agreement
which we have which is a district which
is on both sides
and the high schools on one side
the grade schools are on the other side
of the river
so
if you're
wanting to place this student
if in sau 23 which is just within
five miles of this if an agreement is
made could that superintendent of s823
say i'm going to place this child in the
fairly school which is part of the
rivendell
school district which is an approved
district in the state of new hampshire
but the school is not located in new
hampshire
i'm looking at it and it does fall
through the cracks
and if instead
in
in line two
instead of saying within the district of
residence if you said within the current
district
that would include those other schools
within the district but which aren't in
either the state or the town of
residence
right because they don't reside
in vermont but they go to school in
vermont now and it would give them the
chance to go to another school in
vermont
and so
right now because we either have
current assigned school
or
district of residence
um another district but what if it's the
same district but you but
i don't know how they define distributed
residents and having a kid go to another
school in vermont that i don't want
but if it's a school district which is
approved by our department of education
which has a school in that other state
then that that particular school should
be
a place where you could put a child well
that's what i meant if there's two
schools in vermont in the same district
and all they want to do is move them
from one school to another
in the same district there's only one
elementary oh there is only but there
might be in maine i don't know in one of
these borderlands if you had two towns
two schools
across the border in the same district
somehow you want to make sure they can
just move them from
one district one school building to the
other
i don't think this is a big enough issue
to really you know spend a lot of time
on
but it's a little confusing
i just i do have to i just laughing over
here representative lad that i notice
that you and representative nelson are
co-sponsors
yeah see i beli you know i thought the
the bill had the top part in it uh you
know and consider parental concerns
i know i've signed a lot of things i
don't know what i signed on that you've
never done that of course
or you could be like me and sign on to
things that you don't even like because
they tell you well you can amend it
rep sam moffitt
yeah thank you mr chair um
charter schools is not mentioned
anywhere here and i'll bring it up
before somebody else does uh
should chart public charter schools be
included in any of those lines
well
i've always been an impression a charter
school is a public school
so public school
is here so does this
and i know you signed on to this but
uh i'm not maybe represented
but
you know but seriously i uh
public charter schools often times in
these measures they have both public
school or public charter school and this
has public school but not public charter
school so i mean that's something that
uh
i think in a chartered school
it's a lottery to get into and i don't
think a
school district can just tell
put a kid in the charter school because
it's a lot
right because it's the lottery but and
somebody that's in a chartered school
they can just leave
you know
we've dealt with this manifest education
bill so many times over represent
cornell and it also says the
superintendent will do and there's no
superintendent of a charter school it's
the board of trustees so the
superintendent wouldn't have anything to
do with the charter school
right
yeah and and this may be that internal
move too i'd have to look at the whole
bill here it could be the superintendent
and the district can transfer from a
school in manchester to another school
in manchester
they do it all the time especially when
you're transferring an athlete that's
needed on the other high school's team
hey you can't tell me that stuff doesn't
happen not new not manchester united
okay
okay so i'm sure it happens up in conway
reps of woodcock do you have a question
i i do
twice today i agree with representative
um i i think i think that the the
charter school has a separate enrollment
procedure and you just as you said you
just can't place them in there as well
thank you
okay uh
is there any need we going for the the
prep sponsor's not here we're having fun
and it's nice to have that
so
reps and nelson
my question is my grandson
was having not difficulties but not
happy at a school in beau
he then
went to he's in a charter school down in
salem
now how does that all get paid for and
what happens with that
okay just from the state
so the
home school could be happy for the
person to go somewhere else
so i think we will address this later on
when we take an exec if you really have
some heartburn on this thing do some
research
like the yellow too
okay
so there's no pink cards from anybody
here in the public
a lot of vacancy out there
okay so with that we're
representing
just one last question uh not a if i may
since we're not in that mode uh i'll
point out that there are 14 people uh
watching on youtube this session just
just
so i hope they're having as much fun as
i am
okay thank you very much for closing
this hearing
you
thank you very much we are ready to go
ahead with the 130 hearing today
uh our 1 30 hearing is on hb 1672
relative to misuse of education freedom
account funds and i i welcome the prime
sponsor representative
thank you very much mr chair members of
the committee
dave luno here to introduce house bill
1672. i represent the
people in merrimack county district 10
which are the folks who live in
hopkinton and the western part of
concord um
so house bill 1672 is very similar
to a bill that
that we heard i believe it was last week
house bill 1355
relative to um to preventing fraud
from uh from occurring uh uh within the
uh education freedom account uh program
uh however the difference between 1672
and 1355 is that 1672 is is more
comprehensive
uh than uh than that other bill it um
and it
in addition to um
to the fraud prevention
uh provisions uh in uh in 1355
1672 does two additional things that i
think are very important uh it improves
the integrity of the education freedom
account program
and it has a layer of accountability
um uh in the um
in the language
that uh that
would be used to um
to make sure that um uh that that any
that you know incidents of fraud are not
only detected but um but are are
prevented from being able to uh to
persist within the program
so um so what i'd like to do is is just
spend a couple minutes going through the
bill very quickly and then and then i'd
be happy to
to take um to take questions on it the
first three sections of the um of the
bill on page one i would really lump
into the program integrity category
first of all it um it
it it does uh
it does address some student eligibility
and
and and if
for a uh for an education freedom
account to remain in force
the the student would have to continue
to be eligible for the program so
ineligible students
would
would mean that the education freedom
account terminates
and
enrolling as a full-time student
in a in the resident district public
school would actually cause
cause the student to be ineligible and
would term term terminate sorry the
education freedom account
as opposed to putting on hold the efa
uh the the existing language in the bill
which is uh which is uh crossed out and
so i'm now looking at lines sort of 8
through 12
would would prevent the state from
continuing to make deposits into the efa
but the student's family would continue
to be able to make withdrawals from the
efa
for
for approved educational expenses even
if they were attending their public
school so uh so we feel that's a that's
a conflict with the program
and uh it is a good change
in the name of program integrity
and um
let's see
the um the accountability section
really begins on on on section 4
uh line 21.
and
and what this does is um is
the well it sort of doesn't do this in
order but the the uh
the first thing it does down in the down
on line 29
is um is require the scholarship
organization shall refer suspected cases
of substantial misuse of efa funds to
the attorney general for investigation
so very much similar to house bill 1355
uh replaces the word may with shall
relies on the attorney general's office
to um to do any investigation
but it does actually retain the word
substantial misuse which i think was one
of the uh one of the concerns that
representative cordelli uh brought up
and um
and so uh so we keep that we do uh
remove the intentional
uh part because really that's part of an
investigation that would be uh
you know would be conducted by the
attorney general's office so so
and then um and then on page uh page two
of the bill
um really it's part of the
accountability process i'm sorry part of
the accountability the bill is actually
the process that's used
so um so an efa student being able to
appeal
a a decision to deny eligibility to the
state board
a process that um
that
would would would really look to um
information that is substantially
misrepresented uh or failed to refund
any overpayments in a timely manner
getting rid of the words intentionally
there
and uh and then uh how about halfway
down page two uh the department shall
adopt rules and do rulemaking
uh for uh for the administration of this
chapter and really take that out of the
um the the
responsibilities of the scholarship
organization it's really the department
of education that that should determine
uh the rules behind
the efa program so that's what the bill
does again it's about
accountability and program integrity
it's more comprehensive than the one we
we looked at uh last week i don't think
you need both bills but both to improve
the uh the program with respect to
the determination of fraudulent use of
taxpayer money which obviously we're all
uh looking after to make sure that
taxpayer money isn't uh isn't isn't um
isn't used fraudulently so thank you
very much thank you very much president
are there questions
from the committee
yes representative cornell thank you um
thank you for taking my question in two
places i think you changed from and you
may have talked about this and i missed
it you changed from department to state
board of education
yeah that's that's really really really
a technical correction uh it's the same
thing but the state board of education
is the uh
could you please explain to me that your
your purpose for
uh where you've uh
struck out the word intentional
several times throughout the bill right
could you explain the rationale between
just you know keeping that with the
substantially or or
why you've done this yeah no that's a
that's a great question thank you very
much mr chair the um the word
intentional is really
really a determination of law
as opposed to um substance and i think
the scholarship organization's in a
position
where where it can determine whether or
not um whether or not something that
that that could that might be considered
fraud
they don't know for sure
but possibly it's considered fraud and
it does have have substance to it so the
substantial
uh part of it but determining intent is
something that i think is pretty pretty
complex it's um and i think we heard
some some testimony during 1355
the differences between intent and
substantive
and that some substantive is something
that could be quantified intent is
really a a sort of a finding of law i
guess
and um and the department of justice
would be in a much better position to be
able to make that determination
than um
than the scholarship organization
thank you are there further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
great thank you very much
okay
so are there any uh folks out there in
the
audience that would uh put in a a pink
card or forgot neglected it great okay
with that we're going to close this
hearing
well you know you look at the title of
it and you thought well maybe we would
get a lot of you know
communication
uh for your information uh jennifer iv
has some materials that she's made
copies for you and i think the three
hole punched
uh their their reference uh the bill
that was presented to us earlier today
from representative moffat it's it's the
boilerplate information from the new
hampshire school boards association on
streaming on observing etc in the
classroom
also
i brought up was brought up today by
office of legislative services the new
statutes are out
so
the
we only have one copy for the committee
right now though and it's right here so
i'm going to keep it in the in the
office i'm sure everything in here is
close on the web as well we've been
using it
but
i have those copies upstairs oh you had
the rest of them upstairs
you don't have to lock them down that's
that's heavy
oh you have a cart
i hope they do too
uh
so
you
that's right
thank you
ugh
sleep
well
i
that's the date that they proposed to
however i don't have confirmation on
that yet it's going to be in
i can't honestly say because they're
trying to meld the governor's
report
and that on the same day
and so
um
i'll give him a call over there right
now and find out if they know for sure
i'm also trying to get something on on
that week we would like to take off yeah
and find out so a number of people want
to make it
well i know and some people are trying
to make doctors appointments yeah so
yeah it'd be nice if we really knew all
this yeah
okay let me call and find out i don't
think the thing went around today
i haven't even seen clipboard
um so i'm going to go with five plus one
yeah on the membership there are total
six members on the current bill
okay okay so we'll just stay with six
that make it five and one so
five of funny by the speaker one
appointed by the president
that's fine yeah i think it works all
right great yeah
can i put your name on it too
sure yes absolutely yeah absolutely
and and and the
chairmanship does not rotate
you can make chairmanship too
yeah that's looking current long
no i'm just
what what's the rsa on that
190.
yeah there we are okay yeah
this leave in there yet please
i'll just say that the
initial meeting is taught by the first
named house member
and uh yeah and and the members will
elect a chair
yeah that's right why don't we just
leave it at that yeah that's fine
yeah it wouldn't be in this book because
we repealed it
okay
oh thank you
automatically
no if they're in
be in the legislation because um
it is in other
study committees do you have verbiage
for it
all of us can just put instead i got it
right here in front of me
legislative members
of the committee
shall receive mileage
at the legislative rate
when attending two duties
of the committee
should we have
uh
so maybe um
a member from uh house finance
i think but see this is a puzzle
yeah and this is also policy yeah yeah
i mean i don't think we need to be i
don't think we have to go there no no i
don't think so
yeah leave it up to the speaker
now doesn't replace
yeah it should have everything we did
oh there it is okay thank you
you
once when i
huh
uh
you
um
hello house education committee good to
see you again and thank you for the
opportunity to introduce this bill
my name is representative tony lebranch
and i represent the town of amherst
i come before you today to introduce
house bill 1381 which would change the
current rsa relating to student school
board members
currently the rsa simply is permissive
language allowing for boards to have one
or more high school student
representatives
if the board opts in
what this bill does is make
this common practice across the state
increase representation to one student
representative per high school
every high school has different
challenges different needs
a perfect example of this is my town in
amherst uh what souhegan deals with as
compared to nashville school district or
you know even
north
every school is different every school
has different needs different culture
and i think it's important that these
schools are represented
currently they can alternate or have
more than one representative but
i know nashville specifically
opted to have these representatives
alternate every single year but that
still means
every year one school goes
underrepresented
having a representative from each school
would allow for a more complete picture
of what the district is dealing with
which is you know what the board deals
with
and in talking to the new hampshire
school board association i learned that
most districts have opted into the
current language
of the bill and it would not change
anything and just simply make this a
standardized statewide
norm
and with that i ask that the committee
passed this bill with an ought to pass
motion i like to keep my testimony brief
and i'm happy to answer any questions
and i might defer to the new hampshire
school board association behind me
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question and this is sort of
deja vu because i was the one that put
the original bill in not the original
bill to make it two
or more
uh the thing is what
this is nice and we've discussed it when
about manchester having three schools
what do they do and and that's what came
up when people let's rotate or whatnot
because they don't want to make the
boards too high my problem with this is
shall versus may why do you have a
reason for saying they must do it
thank you for the question uh
the reason why i changed the may to a
show
was so that every school board that has
a high school within it would have a
student representative i believe that
having a student representative
from each of these high schools is
important when the board is making
decisions to see what is actually
happening
at the school
because there's a lot of things
taxpayers and voters and even school
board members don't even know what's
going on
at the schools you know
i was at the high school i was a high
schooler when the vaping epidemic began
and you know this administration was
blindsided by that
you know leaky ceilings uh no heating in
some of the classrooms these are some of
the things that i dealt with at souhegan
high school
luckily we did have a student
representative
and you know they have started working
on those issues but i believe that it
should be
a statewide norm that there is a student
representative on these boards so that
we know what's happening in our schools
yeah when i did it we had two
yes we had two on ours and we saw laura
always had one that's why i did the two
but we still kept it in may so thank you
thank you thank you for taking my
question it said from each high school
and as i said manchester does have four
high schools and right now i think they
rotate they each have a representative
but they rotate them and they don't go
and and the school board and the
students are happy with that setup would
they be able to continue doing that or
would all four of them
have to go every
meeting
thank you for the question
uh i knew manchester was one of the
concerns i had with this bill but
in talking with the new hampshire school
board association
and talking with representatives from
manchester uh to my knowledge currently
manchester is planning on consolidating
their schools uh so there will be fewer
high schools in manchester uh which will
mean less representatives and uh
secondary to that um
i don't believe that it was necessarily
a bad thing to have a representative
from each high school at every meeting
obviously some people can't attend those
meetings just like representatives
sometimes can't attend house sessions
i believe it's the same
issue here and
representatives from each school would
be welcome at all the board
meetings
thank you thank you representative
taking my question and i think the bill
is terrific every school should have a
school bus should have one of those um
and we're fortunate in sau 9 and conway
we have a very active young lady that
did a great job uh have you thought or
have any dialogue been i see other
fellow representatives from this
committee on the board have you folks
talked at all about having perhaps
having allowing the school the student
school would represent to have a vote
i have had people thank you for the
question i have had individuals and
other representatives come up to me and
talk about having a voting member
um the reason i did not include it in
this bill is
there's a lot of
uncertainty on whether legally if the
individual's below the age of 18 if they
can vote on school board matters
as they are not registered voters that
was one concern brought up to me
another concern uh is you know from the
taxpayers having an unelected
person
be on the board and making these
decisions which
i understand that i necessarily don't
agree with that but i that's the reason
i didn't want to include it in this bill
perhaps it could be another piece of
legislation at a further date but i just
wanted to at least make it so that there
is a student representative from each
high school on the boards thank you
chairman thank you
thank you mr chair and welcome
representative lebranch to house
education
do you happen to know how many
schools that have public high schools do
not currently have a student on the
board
thank you for the question i would defer
that to the new hampshire school board
association which is behind me but to my
knowledge
i know of no school districts at least
in my area that do not have a school
board a student member on the school
board
are there further questions from the
committee
not saying seeing any thank you very
much thank you
looks like becky wilson you're up
new hampshire school boards association
welcome
thank you representative ladd and
members of the house education committee
for the record i'm becky wilson director
of governmental relations for the new
hampshire school boards association we
want to thank representative lebranch
for bringing this forward this bill and
the co-sponsors of this bill as well for
really highlighting the very important
topic of student voice and perspective
on our local school boards
we share the sponsor's
feelings that this is a very integral
part of gaining
the perspective of student body from a
number of different buildings across
different districts
at the table
to answer some of the questions that had
come up previously we had discussed
that in terms of the school boards
association supporting this bill we
would approve that this idea as long as
it was not a voting member of the school
board that's to allow boards to handle
how they want to have a student
representative on the board
and the ways in which those people are
either elected by the student body or
they're on a rotating basis
getting people from different grade
levels it's not always the seniors
necessarily that are sitting on your
school boards sometimes it's freshmen so
to make sure that
there was some latitude for school
boards to think about how they wanted to
include these student reps in the
conversations that happen at the board
level
the other reason that we would support
them not being a voting member are for
things like non-public sessions other
kinds of meetings that the school board
may need to hold where that student
would probably not be
part of those meetings and it would be
difficult to exclude somebody that was a
voting member of the board
in terms of any other
pieces
our delegate assembly each year our
membership votes on resolutions that
guide our advocacy throughout the year
this year we had a number of school
boards that brought forward resolutions
asking for scholarships to recognize
their student school board
representatives so we have put that in
place at the school boards association
this year we have five scholarships for
students who have served on the board
at some level over the course of their
years it is only open obviously to
seniors to apply but they could have
served any number of times during the
four years of high school so
we support this bill and i'm happy to
take any questions thank you very much
questions to the school board yes
representative
mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you ms
wilson for taking my question i'm going
to
ask you the same question that i just
asked representative lebranch
do you have any sense of how many
communities that have public high
schools do not have student
representation on the board
to my knowledge thank you for the
question to my knowledge there are not
any boards do not have some sort of
student voice at some level but there
may be boards that do not have a person
from every single high school in their
district that is somehow connected to
the board so it could be again that
students are participating on a rotating
basis
that they have somebody for one semester
but perhaps not the other semester or
they're asking for that student voice on
particular topics but not at every
meeting so i don't have a specific
number of how many boards never include
students
as a
official representative on the board but
we certainly could get that information
for you with at least with our
membership
follow up
i'm just pretty sure that there's no
student on the bedford new hampshire
school board
so
i i i
will put that out there as a question
could you check for me ms wilson to see
whether or not there is uh i just
visually there is not and i'm interested
in uh what the alternatives for student
input are
if they're not seating somebody at the
table absolutely i'm happy to get that
for you thank you you're welcome
i have a very short probably a very
simple question i can't respond to how
do
best of you know how are students
identified are they appointed by the
school board or are they
elected by the student council within
the high school how might that happen it
happens differently at each school board
and each district some students are
elected by the student body
some students are
included as a school board rep as part
of their national honor society
service hours that's one of the ways in
which they're meeting those things some
are
appointed as part of a course competency
potentially to maybe one semester you
would have students from
ap u.s history or ap civics who are
potentially serving on the board for
their time in that course it really does
depend on the district and i think that
was one of the reasons that we wanted to
support
not mandating necessarily how the person
would be identified to be the school
board rep for the student body that we
would leave that up to local districts
and local schools to determine that
then
is it so then that there are some
school boards that have
rotating
students on maybe by the month or
bi-monthly or
yes that's accurate and i believe that
for some districts that have multiple
high schools right now that is how they
do it in terms of rotating a person from
each high school over time
not necessarily each high school at
every meeting but for example if there's
four quarters and there's four high
schools in a certain district you may
have each quarter one high school is
assigned to assign a student rep member
for that amount of time thank you very
much are there further questions from
the committee yes representative cornell
this is really just a statement i just
want to say it really is a good idea and
i don't know if everybody knows that the
student
board member
in manchester just wrote the new dress
code policy for the entire school
district and it was accepted and voted
on by the school board and that was
written by the student so
they really do a good job
thank you
further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you
are there any uh
other folks that would like to testify
regarding student participation on on
the school boards
not and we don't have any further pink
cards up here so
we will then close this hearing
15 minutes
1679.
no so we do another committee like jim
grenier did years ago and there were a
few things he did which were very
positive
but i came up with just one big battle
because there's those that don't want
them dissolved and there's those that
want to get out oh absolutely um
but
you know
this is this was part of their couple
yeah yes we have other bills
that's exactly right i don't want to see
the whole thing dissolved and gone
because that's just going sort of the
opposite way we want to go as far as
you know cut down some of our
administrative costs or cut down this
look at our structural organization of
the whole thing
so this would not be the bill that i
would choose i don't go forward with no
um
no no we don't pick one of the others
you know i've also been thinking is
there a need for us to have i'd like to
commit a whole discussion on this and
bring folks in and have a
but you know here we are with a
dissolution of popular school districts
and you hear so much about from delanger
and a whole lot of people i want to get
out in this
look what's showing up nobody's showing
up for it
uh is it that they don't know it's being
held uh because there's a lot of stuff
going on in education and you know
you know
so
but
if this is all we have is this the
interest level that's that's my concern
here
we're not even getting
so
yeah
the only other way of doing it is really
setting up a committee of the whole or a
subcommittee but when do we do that yeah
right we're not going to have time to do
that is this a really built that's not
an early bill
um
certainly a lot of financial
ramifications
1679 maybe it is
yeah let's see
it's not is it no i didn't think it was
so
so we have through march
so we could
what are the other two titles
i'm sorry
those were co-op apportionments
to
relative school reapportionment
and 99
uh
this whole thing is like there are
pockets of problems yeah that's right
but it's not a gl it's not a universal
well i'm in a cooperative school
district
and haven't was getting pretty tired
paying the bill
uh so
there's interest up there but it's not
at the level where they're saying we
want to get out
they realize the dynamics it's just like
jumping over a very high hurdle
and if i look around on the committee
here
who who would have an interest in that
on this committee besides
okay
well linda's here
yeah well i know that so there's linda
um
oh i'm certainly interested i'm
interested too
but i'm also interested in the founding
finance bill you got going
so i i guess we can chew and walk
and chew gum and walk at the same time
the question i say is
trying to is this the year
to doing a high-powered you know
yeah
i know it i know it
politically
you
uh we're not going there
when i lived in maine i was just hoping
they cut the bridge down in kittery
okay
and that's what chased me to alaska
okay uh here we are now it's time to go
ahead and introduce the next bill it's
hp
1679 relative to the disillusion and
repeal of cooperative school districts
the prime sponsor is not here
representative cordelli he was unable to
attend today
so we're going to have representative
boom
introduce the bill on his behalf
thank you mr chairman and
thank you education committee
bill relative to the dissolution and
repeal of cooperative school districts
there are a number of people here going
to speak but just so the many years that
i've been on
the education committee just about every
year we've had builds on cooperative
school districts one of the problems we
have in the state is every cooperative
school district is different
so when schools want to leave it
depending on what the
cooperative district is
so that's always been an issue so this
bill i know a lot of us disgusted over
the summer on what to do about
cooperative school districts and one of
the things that when i want we just get
rid of them so one of the things that
this is for discussion and we'll have
more debate on it and what not on what
we can do about it so with that
thank you
thank you very much representative boom
are there any questions for
representative boom it's your
opportunity
reps and lakers
i don't know if you know the answer to
this but thank you for taking my
question anyway
um
what if a cooperative school district
doesn't want to disband
well that's one of the problems we have
a lot of them want to or dissolution to
dissolve or whatnot or remove themselves
from the cooperative school district and
that's one of the problems we've had
like i said nearly every year i've been
here since 2008
and but the problem is it's always been
a problem
and
and what to do about it so that's
why you know glenn put this bill in
representative put this bill in but the
stuff we have discussed on what to do
and this i think just opens up
discussion on what we can do
well i've i since we got a question yeah
i tried to but you weren't looking yes
thank you
no no no but foreign
since this has come in other
cooperative districts that are very
happy
have asked do they still have to
dissolve when they're very happy or can
this be
somehow amended so that
they don't have to i don't know that's
why we sort of hope the discussion and i
know there's one cooperative school
district which isn't a cooperative
school district the town of derry is a
cooperative school district with east
derry which is no longer exists because
they became found of derry but they're
still a cooperative school district
thank you further questions
thank you very much thank you uh next uh
speaker will be representative tony
pamonti
thank you mr chair and thank you
committee for taking my testimony here
um i will say that i am not the
mr cordelli representative cordelie is
the main sponsor on this bill
and i didn't realize he was here today
so i'm going to make a few statements or
words for him
um on this uh
on this uh house bill 1679
um there
is a way to negotiate
uh the
amount of money that a student would pay
and that could be done within the towns
whether they have two representatives
that would negotiate with the school
board
and they would be able to
go to the same schools
but
maybe at a cost it would be
a little bit less and more desirable to
them
uh i know this there's a lot of uh
discussion now about how certain school
boards are acting
and and this may solve that problem you
know we just have to see i think the
rest of the
risk the information would come out
during the your executive session
but uh it could have something to reduce
in taxes
it could reduce your budgets
there's a number of things that could
play into effect and i i don't know how
those will
uh come out as as we sit right here now
thank you very much
are there any questions for the
representative yes represent woodcock
thank you i thank you for another
question can you tell me how many
cooperative school districts there are
on the state um i do not know
and this is this just strictly
cooperative or regional schools involved
in this as well
uh again i believe it's just the
cooperative school districts but
um
i'm not fully uh thank you voiced on
that thank you further yes
representative lakas
can i ask you the same question
would you be amenable to amending this
to allow a school district where all the
towns involved voted to
stay in the cooperative school district
to get to state a cooperative school
district
unfortunately this bill is now in your
committee and it has not much to do with
me so any amendments that you make
would be your own
thank you i just wanted your opinion
thank you thank you very much
representative moffat uh a clerk
question for you representative did you
say fortunately or unfortunately is with
this this committee
it is with
i didn't know whether uh whether i did
say fortunately but it is with your your
uh
your purview now
thank you
are there further questions
nazi hands thank you very much
becky wilson of the school boards
association
good afternoon again
chairman lad and members of the
committee for the record becky wilson
director of governmental relations for
the new hampshire school boards
association
um we're here today in opposition of
this bill however we would like to make
some recommendations as opposed to just
stating why this bill
is difficult for us to move forward with
as opposed to trying to solve the
numerous individual issues that have
come to this board to this committee
regarding co-op districts in the
multiple bills we would really like to
consider whether or not this committee
could move forward with developing a
study commission to look at each of
these items
in its entirety
together and the impact of each one and
how they interplay
with the cooperative districts to answer
a question that was just asked there are
42 or around 42 regional or cooperative
school districts in the state
it's a high number of districts that
this these kinds of bills around
cooperative districts would certainly
affect that
we did speak with chairman ladd earlier
in this session in response to some of
the other cooperative bills that have
come forward
and we did
bring with us today in our testimony
some potential language that could be
used to develop that study commission
moving forward
with all of the complexities involved
with regional and cooperative districts
to try to look at each individual item
without considering the impact of
each one on the other and the domino
effects that happen when certain bills
are put through for one aspect of
cooperatives and not looking at the
entire system as a whole we really feel
like that that would be
detrimental to districts across new
hampshire
i'm happy to try to take any questions i
will say that barrett was planning to be
here today to testify but he's been
pulled away unexpectedly and as he
stated last week our areas of expertise
are
very
combined but together we have very
different areas of expertise so if there
are questions that i can answer today
i'm happy to answer them and if not i'm
happy to get the answer for you thank
you very much are there any questions of
the school board so represent luna
thank you very much mr chair and thanks
very much mr wilson for uh for sticking
with us this afternoon uh you mentioned
that there are 42 cooperatives is that
42 municipalities that are in
cooperatives or is that 42 cooperatives
i believe just 42 cooperative or
regional school districts and and so
i'll follow up on that and so that would
involve um
a lot more
maybe double that or three times that in
terms of municipalities yes it would
certainly be a much higher number than
just 42. okay thanks and then a final
question on related to this are there
any municipalities that are members of
uh maybe at the same time a non you know
a single school district as well as a
cooperative school district
like concord
yes certainly
yes
yes certainly there are municipalities
that obviously run their own district
school and then are also part of a
larger cooperative or regional district
especially at the higher grade levels so
it gets complicated fast cooperatives
are very complicated thank you becky
any further questions
uh becky i have uh has the school boards
association we've looked at this issue
every year i've been in the house so
that's 14 years that i know of
um and we know that there are if you
take all the municipalities or towns
that are part of these co-ops
according to the fiscal note in the back
side we're talking at least 117
communities
and but there is a
note in the
fiscal note here
that by doing so we create 90 new school
districts throughout the state my
question then is
has your association looked at what
what additional costs it's going to take
an administration and
costs associated with forming a new
district would be
no but thank you for the question uh
representative we have not looked um at
that granular level in terms of what the
actual cost would be to try to
move in this direction i think it's you
know it's certainly a resource issue not
only fiscally but just in terms of
getting staffing and superintendents and
those kinds of things that would need to
be put into effect if this were to go
forward it just the resources in all
areas i think would be certainly tapped
out to a very high extent
thank you are there further questions
yes represent woodcock thank you uh
good afternoon again thank you um
i just want to make sure i'm clear on
the understanding
my interpretation or what i think the
understanding is
a cooperative school and i know they've
talked about francis down the small but
the cooperative school
in terms of the disillusion as presented
in this bill
is the same for example kingswood
regional high school
so all the regional schools
are considered the same as cooperative
schools is that correct thank you for
the question yes that would be our
interpretation
thank you so much thank you ruffled
interled you're welcome
further questions from the committee
not seeing hands thank you very much
thank you
do we have any other cards
deborah house
aft new hampshire
welcome
huh is this on now good
good afternoon chairman laden members of
the committee i am
happy that you have given me this time
to address you and share my members
concerns about hb 1679
and i have
written testimony that i'll give you
after we're here to oppose hb 1679
this bill mandates the breakup of
cooperative school districts and from
our perspective it would hurt kids and
families by arbitrarily disrupting
children's education
it wastes time and money that should be
going to our students and they have so
many needs right now we really can't
afford to be
spending it setting up 90 new school
districts it would interfere in towns
and parents educational decisions
and also decisions that voters have made
over the past decades
they've likely raised property taxes
it would set up a backdoor pressure to
take up vouchers and and send kids to
charter schools to create unnecessary
state bureaucracy as there would be much
needed support to set up those 90 new
school districts
for decades new hampshire towns that
were too small to finance their own
school systems have banded together in
cooperative school districts and as we
just heard they're currently about 42
cooperative and regional school
districts mostly in rural areas of the
state
those districts provide real benefits to
our students they're a great way for
smaller towns to share school buildings
teachers staff offering cost and capital
expenses and avoid duplicating
administrative systems they give
students in smaller towns access to
academics sports art music and other
services and programs that single towns
alone can't afford
and they're flexible
for example some towns just share a high
school and have their own elementary and
middle schools so
the individual towns and districts
decide what they want and the voters
have a say
mandating that those all be dissolved is
going against local troll going against
what the voters over time have decided
decided
students and families could find
themselves suddenly without the teachers
staff school and programs and services
they've always had the bill would
arbitrarily disrupt education for
thousands of kids across our state
the bill gives towns who are now part of
cooperative districts two costly and
equally bad choices
they either have to suddenly create
their own district and this bill has a
deadline of 2025 that's hardly any time
to plan
uh or pay whatever it costs to
send their students
uh to
another town under a tuition agreement
or perhaps to another
you know
non-public school in an area
or maybe it's going to force more
families to take up the
efa program
which we all know is well over budget
and
there's a lot of questions about how
that's running
we've heard the argument that there's a
lot of problems in cooperative districts
but there already is a solution for
towns that want to get out of
cooperative districts it exists in
current law
this
proposed solution is like grabbing a
sledgehammer when a scaffold will do
polling shows polling that we did back
in december with heart research shows
that granite state voters
support their local public schools
of them want stronger investment in
their public schools
72 percent of them
want to see their public schools
supported they don't want to see
vouchers they don't want to see more
charter schools they want to see their
public schools supported
our children right now need stability
social and emotional supports and a safe
and welcoming environment
in every school so we can help them not
only recover from disruptions of the
past two years
they don't need to have their schooling
and their social networks thrown into
chaos
so in conclusion
please
stop
hb1679 let's keep our school districts
going forward let's focus on what the
kids need and
not
take a sledgehammer to something that
needs a scalpel
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
that's it
are there any other individuals in the
uh chairs out front that would like to
testify in this that may not have put a
pink card in
so it looks like we have the pink cards
which we have that we've gone through
though so with that i'm going to close
this hearing thank you
that's okay
theresa come on up
no i believe this is the last card
theresa wyman canterbury new hampshire
welcome thank you
thank you
i am here as a private citizen am i too
loud
i can talk wicked loud if you want me to
but i know that i have friends and that
there are many others who share my
opinion and perhaps can't be here
i am appalled by this bill
this country was founded by my ancestors
with a strong value on public education
that means everybody goes to school that
doesn't mean charter schools and
vouchers that means a public school that
every child can go to
the puritans started that in 1639.
although i myself am a retired rn i come
from a family of teachers so i think i
have some credibility in this my mom
taught kindergarten for many years
including managing a private
kindergarten town that didn't have a
public one
my dad's teaching career started
by teaching sixth grade in
the tilton northfield district uh
technically the building is in
northfield
and it ended with him being a highly
respected member of the faculty of the
university of massachusetts
i'm a product of public education
i started school in canterbury new
hampshire and i
my finished my
bachelor of science at umass i would
have preferred to have gone to unh
but
umass was a whole lot thriftier choice
in-state tuition there was quite
affordable
and unless anybody have any question
about it i did not get a cup because my
dad was on the faculty
i had a key to his office if i wanted to
study there but it was the other end of
campus from the nursing program so
so that's my background my reasons for
opposing this bill there are three basic
reasons one has to do with education
to those who have started this bill and
i'm not sure whom i should be looking at
please tell me how it would be
advantageous for high school students to
attend a smaller school with fewer
choices
that just doesn't make sense to me for
example would there be one teacher for
all the sciences instead of perhaps one
in biology one in chemistry one in
physics
planning curriculum takes time
planning in several subjects takes more
time than planning different levels of
the same
subject
and i can tell you that teachers put
plenty of time into their planning by
the time i was 12 i said there's no way
i'm going to be a teacher
it was too much work i'm not sure being
a nurse was a whole lot less but i
didn't know that at the time
and what i say about planning curriculum
etc that applies to all fields whether
it's english foreign languages
how many languages are you going to have
in a school that
doesn't have enough teachers to have
more than one
and what about things like computers
that
i can't speak to that i can barely make
one run
and how about
the many things that are not part of the
formal curriculum
sports a lot of people like that it's
it's life-saving to many kids theater
music
dance band
art orchestra debate team
education involves exposure to new
things
a regional school may provide students
with an opportunity to know people from
different demographics
the world which they will enter as
adults will be filled with people from
all kinds of backgrounds
let our kids begin to experience this
please
less is more i don't think so
okay that's education financial
if towns in a given district for
whatever reason find that their regional
school district is not working they
already have the option of reconsidering
this alliance
there are some people in canterbury
right now who are considering a study
and i believe at this point it's just a
study
of whether being in a regional school
with belmont is really the best fit
this includes the option of building our
own high school though this bill is
superfluous why are you wasting your
time with it
if regional schools were to be
dismantled there would undoubtedly be a
large increase in property taxes in many
towns
those of us from a thrifty yankee
background object to paying more unless
we get more
in this case as i noted previously we
would be getting less
i don't know how many times i've told
people the education of our kids in town
is important to everyone i don't mind
paying taxes for that but i sure as hell
mind paying more taxes for less
education
and if you think i'm emotional now will
you get to philosophy of local control
what about local control i believe that
many of the people sponsoring this bill
are generally in favor of more not less
local control
so why do you feel the school should be
regulated by the state government
and i might point out that the state of
new hampshire doesn't do much to fund
education anyhow there's plenty of
evidence going back to claremont about
that and i'm old enough to remember a
lot of that in the newspapers
as it is largely the town property taxes
that pay for education it seems it would
be only fair for the townspeople not the
legislators from concord who represent
only a small number of school districts
in the state
would be the ones deciding how our
children are educated
no one sponsoring this bill represents
my district or me
i do not want them dictating this level
of control over my town schools
i don't have kids in the school i'm
talking about the kids in my town
following the logic presented in this
bill perhaps we should be considered
going really local i don't often get to
say i'm too young but i'm four years too
young to have gone to a one-room
schoolhouse in my town
in closing
i cannot help but wonder if this is in
reality an attempt to discredit and
undermine public education
i question the actual motivation with
this so-called educational bill i
believe those have who have written it
if you were to be honest in your hearts
and heart of hearts heart of hearts
you would have to admit that you are
attempting something
unspeakably unpatriotic and that is to
dismantle public education
thank you for taking my testimony thank
you very much for coming today are there
any questions
i don't see any hands-on thank you very
much or just just one thank you mr uh
thank you so much for coming in do you
want to leave us your written testimony
i'd be glad to this is just
when i read about this this morning i i
had a thousand things i wanted to do
today besides coming out in the cold
but since i'm not clever with computers
i wrote myself an email
and i had to get to go to the library to
print it so who wants my one page right
here let's bring it right over to the
gentleman right there and they'll pass
it up to us
thank you very much
thank you miss wyman for coming down
from canterbury
are there any other folks out there last
call for pink cards
not seeing any so at this time i'm going
to close the hearing down
oh
now
that's
you